[Music]
when i first started i got a phone call
from a woman whose daughter was an
equestrian
and the woman was very upset because her
daughter's coach had been removed had
been banned by the center for safe sport
for sexual misconduct
i was assuming that she was calling to
kind of talk through what that really
meant
instead she called me to ask me to
remove him from our disciplinary
database even though he had been removed
with cause because it was her daughter's
coach and that was the only coach that
her daughter would work with
and i just found it just mind-blowing
that
here you have a mother who
i'm sure loves her daughter very much
and wants nothing but the best for her
child but at the same time was willing
to put her child at risk with someone
who shouldn't have been around kids
who had done some pretty terrible things
because she wanted her child to win
what i didn't realise when i first began
reporting the story is how deep the
divisions run with an equestrian
this is a community that has been torn
apart by safe sport
safesport is an agency that was
established by congress in 2017
to effectively be the watchdog over all
olympic sporting communities when it
comes to sexual misconduct
the center's been criticized by a number
of olympic sports for not doing enough
to support survivors
but what surprised me about the
equestrian community in particular is
that here we're seeing members actually
push back against safe sport and
defensively accused i was kind of like
okay safe sport is this third party
organization but they need to like mind
their own business in a way and stay out
of the us ef
not only are they challenging the
centre's process but they are demanding
for the reinstatement of some athletes
who have been brought down by the centre
this was the first time that these
people were being held accountable and
accountability makes people
uncomfortable
equestrian like many sports is having to
kind of have a reckoning within their
community and some are not happy about
it
these families are wealthy we're talking
about the daughters of billionaires of
rock stars of royalty
this is a community that is not afraid
to stand up for what it believes in to
challenge or to question authorities and
is definitely not afraid to push back
when it thinks they're getting it wrong
people can mobilize may change that's
how the center for state sport started
right people were angry they wanted
change and they saw change happen so
i've got no issue with that but you
gotta ask yourself like why
are you vocal against an organization
that is holding people accountable
when i was nine years old eight or nine
years old i went to sacramento
international and it was a world cup
qualifiers was a big 160 class i
remember just watching that class
thinking that's going to be me one day i
had no doubt in my mind that that's what
i was going to be doing
two years later same show
i was sitting in those same stands
i was watching the world cup qualifier
and rich won it i remember being so
amazed by rich and flexible and i
thought okay that's who i need to ride
with to get to the top of the sport
rich fellas is an olympic team veteran
he won the 2012 world cup final in the
netherlands
he was probably one of the most
respected and well-known trainers in the
country rich fellas and flexible 26
points six months ago
[Applause]
i talked to many young women who at the
age of 14 or 15
moved across cities in order to be able
to ride at an elite level with a top
trainer
some who even moved to different
countries because they knew that was the
trainer that was going to get them on
the path of where they wanted to go
where they felt like they needed to go
when i was 14 is when i decided to move
to the fellers
they were in oregon and i was in
california
and so it was kind of agreed upon by
everyone that i would go and stay with
them
maggie from the day she was born was
always very independent she would never
even hold my hand when she was two she
just was so intense and so focused and
so driven
so when she decided she wanted to go up
to oregon and ride with the fowlers we
said okay we can make that happen
maggie's routine was so straightforward
and so strong you know she would get up
at 7 am she would get ready she would
drive to the barn
if she wasn't riding at the barn she was
working at the barn and then you know
she would go home take a shower do some
school work go to sleep and get up the
next day and go to the barn
your relationship with your trainer is
probably the strongest relationship in
your life
they build you up and they teach you
everything you know
and you grow as a person when you're
training with them
the more time you spend with them the
more you trust them
and they are the strongest voice in your
life
i think that that relationship is
important
but i think in my case the line is
crossed and i think in a lot of cases
the line gets crossed
maggie carrick under the watchful eye of
rich fellas as well of course
we had just had a
christmas party it was like a big barn
christmas party the fellows invited all
their friends
and nothing happened there it was two
days after
i got this call
and he was like you know something's
just been building up inside me the past
six months i'm crazy about you i have
these really strong feelings about you
you can't tell anyone it's very personal
but he's like
it's okay don't worry i'll get it under
control and everything will be fine i'll
go back to normal
and i remember just sitting in shock
how old were you i was 16.
[Music]
the moment the announcement was made
that i was going to be the ceo
i remember later that day getting a
direct message on facebook of all places
of this woman
who happened to be an equestrian
basically warning me of what i was
stepping into
and that i really needed to take a close
look at the entire community at the
center for state sport because you know
it was going to be it was going to be
tough for me
mom don't you want to know why coach
keeps texting me so much the u.s center
first day sport is a non-profit 501c3
organization that opened its doors back
in 2017 which is right in the middle of
the midst of the larry nassar scandal
with usa gymnastics this morning dozens
of larry nassar's victims will have
their voices heard in court there is now
nowhere left for you to hide larry more
than 160 women say larry nassar sexually
abused them
before the center for state sport opened
there really wasn't an organization in
this country in this world that focused
on the issues that we do within the
olympic paralympic movement national
governing bodies were really responsible
for
investigating any sort of allegations
that may have come their way which some
may handled well some they didn't and
you know what we saw was that there was
just a conflict of interest to have an
organization start to investigate
allegations of abuse within their own
ranks
the center did a study last year where
we looked at data coming from 4 000
athletes across the olympic movement and
we got representation from every sport
within the olympic and paralympic which
was significant and what we found was
that you know 93
of athletes who had experienced abuse
had not reported it that is a
significant number and very troubling as
a movement and as a community and as an
organization we have to do more to
really help people understand what abuse
looks like but also to help them become
more comfortable in reporting it
that is the only way that we're going to
start shifting the narrative
[Music]
it's hard to understand until you're put
in that situation
but he was the person who was fully
developing me and to who i was becoming
and that is kind of the power imbalance
of it all and so i just
blindly trusted him
um and i do have to say in the beginning
i did say no i was very
firm and i tried to be supportive
because you know i did care about him i
did have strong relationship with him
but i did say no several times
and i was like that's not the way i feel
about you
and then he kind of kept pushing
and i kind of just accepted that
[Music]
and then that slowly progressed into
like
me being at the barn with him and he'd
pull me aside on a horse and be like i
just had to tell you that i'm in love
with you
and
he was like i never understood how i
could feel love like this until now
um
and you'd say stuff like this is too
good to lose
that's probably when i'd say that i
started to actually love him
i think it lasted around six months
[Music]
it was just after his 17th birthday that
their relationship turned sexual
and in the state of oregon the age of
consent is 18.
maggie and rich's relationship actually
ended quite publicly at a horse show in
michigan
she had traveled there with him and his
wife and his son and they were all
sharing an airbnb near the show grounds
and one night his wife shelly fellas
walked in on them together
a lot of the blame was put on me even
though i didn't really know what i'd
really gotten myself into i was kind of
just following the leader who's rich
i called my mom she came to michigan she
brought me to a hotel and i remember
just looking out the hotel window
looking at the concrete below me
thinking
i understand why people kill themselves
now like
it was
felt like the only release of pain and i
was in so much pain
and i
i felt like i was
on i just lost everything
you know i had lost the person who i
loved
the family who i loved i lost
you know my trainers um
my whole support system
just everything crashed down real quick
it was so bad
i think for months and months i just
operated as
i just have to keep maggie alive and i
have to keep my younger daughter
functioning
that's all i could do and i couldn't
look up
from any of it
in the aftermath of all this maggie
wasn't allowed to return to their stable
so her and her four horses
never came back
that raised a lot of questions
and on top of that she's a teenager she
uses social media and she was posting
videos of herself crying photographs of
her with rich song lyrics talking about
how she was in love with him
more than a dozen people reported the
relationship between rich fellas and
maggie kiering to the united states
center for safe sport but safe sport
couldn't take any action without
maggie's consent
so she decided six months after the
relationship had ended when she had gone
through depression
suicidality trying to
get back on a horse again trying to ride
again trying to find herself again that
she was going to report him to the
united states center for safe sport
and when she did the center acted
immediately police arrested richard
fellers a prominent competitor and
trainer in the equestrian industry and
it was the organization the u.s center
for a safe sport that provided the
information to police this here is the
61-year-old's booking photo taken monday
after police arrested fellers on four
counts of second-degree sexual abuse
rich fellas was issued a lifetime ban
from safe sport
he didn't pursue arbitration but he has
pleaded not guilty to the charges in
court
a trial date is expected to be set in
april and he declined to comment for the
story a lot of people stood by rich when
the initial allegations came out a lot
of people attacked maggie and what we've
seen in the aftermath is this growing
sense of people realizing that actually
this is a problem in the sport the
grooming of young riders by their
coaches in powerful positions
has happened and is still happening
today
up to the end of 2021 safesport had
issued 47 sanctions against the
equestrian community and this is quite a
lot when you compare it to tennis an
organization that has eight times as
many members but has had only 35
sanctions up until that point you say
the safe sport needs a lot of work um is
this not enough as it's not a strong
enough system
to protect younger gymnasts in place
right now safe sports been around for
about five years and the center has
seen its fair share of criticism we have
seen um gymnasts like ali rassman
testifying before congress saying that
safe sport doesn't do enough to support
survivors they try to avoid um
doing it like they'll say you need to
pass it on to this person and then the
person that we actually report to you
will say will actually go back to safe
sport it's like they play hot potato
with who should take the report we've
seen sports calling out safe sport for
taking too long in its investigative
process for asking too much of survivors
demanding that they deliver too much
evidence to prove an allegation
we pride ourselves on being very
thorough
some investigations might take a few
weeks some may take a few months others
have been known to take years just
because of the complexity of the
investigation this is not something that
we take lightly because this has so much
impact
on people's lives it is not something
that we are
willing to kind of cut corners on
equestrian is the only sport that is
mobilizing against safe sport in defense
of the accused
we have seen members of this community
create anti-safe sport petitions that
have garnered thousands of signatures
we've seen it create non-profit
organizations which have raised over 2.5
million to lobby congress and challenge
safe sports authority to try and limit
the powers that the watchdog has
within the equestrian community the main
criticisms against safe sport are that
it lacks due process
that it lacks transparency and that it
is effectively labeling coaches guilty
until proven innocent
the question about the extent of the
division within the sport is a good one
my sense from my conversations with
colleagues peers
is that it runs pretty
was a little deep in 1989 ray texal won
the two most prestigious middle finals
in the u.s he's a well-known trainer
he's at the top level of his sport and
he also feels as though safe sport has
been operating like a secret court
the feeling of it is you don't know
what's going on this is not falling in
the criminal justice system or the
justice system
it's a step towards it and i think that
that's where a lot of the division comes
from is
not wanting to support something of that
nature that's operating in that way
but at the same time supporting its
message
and and its purpose
and there's a conflict there
people in my community afraid of related
to safe sport is
very specifically the use of c sport
as a weapon
whether that's for retribution
whether that's displeasure with somebody
of course that's a very scary
proposition
so my early thoughts of safe sport were
definitely influenced by the people
around me
and a lot of people were trainers
i heard things you know like say sports
a witch hunt these are innocent trainers
not doing anything and
if clients don't like them they can go
after them for absolutely anything
i never really understood what safe
sport was until i actually needed to go
through with it
um and it's a lot different from what
people think
i kind of was like i'm just gonna make a
social media post it's gonna be over
gonna keep moving on and then so many
women started reaching out to me so many
women and men of all ages talking about
their stories
and i was like okay wait i'm not the
only one this is a huge problem in our
industry that is not talked about enough
um all it's talked about is how safe
sports a witch hunt and how
safe sports awful and how we need to get
rid of it and how you know how could
this be put in place
and i think a lot of times some people
forget that i'm still like an 18 year
old girl who's
coming out of the situation it's not
like it's 10 years behind me it's still
fairly close
[Music]
one of the things that the equestrian
community has struggled with is that
it's seen some of the most prestigious
trainers athletes and olympic champions
brought down by safe sport
one thing i've definitely come to
realize over the course of this
reporting is that this is a sport that
doesn't like to watch its heroes fall
for me safe sport became the most
polarizing when
the
person i think in our community that we
all looked to
the most the one with the biggest voice
george morris my former mentor and
trainer when he was set down i think
that was really maybe one of the more
significant moments when it really hit
hard for many people that this was real
and serious
when george morris was removed from
sport i don't think that anyone inside
of state sport could have predicted the
just emotional
like outcry of of that decision um it
was something that we had never seen
before the i stand with george hashtag
was was circulating and people were just
really just angry with the center
because this was someone who had been in
this community for decades he was still
coaching he was a pillar with his
community this guy had his own action
figures like this was someone that they
really looked up to and so for him to be
called out like this for him to be
removed people were just angry
within 48 hours of the george morris ban
a group called i stand with george have
popped up on facebook and it had more
than 4 200 members
they sent angry emails to safe sport
they called the center they did
everything they could
to demand his reinstatement
they didn't believe that george morris
should be brought down by allegations
dating back to the 1970s
they want to know why and how safe sport
can operate outside and beyond the scope
of the criminal justice system not
having a statute of limitations in place
allowed people to one
take their time to come to the center
for state sport when they felt ready
but also know that we were not going to
you know put some arbitrary timeline
on um on when you could do that
and you know while this was novel i
think back in 2017 when we opened up the
organization
states across this country are starting
to reverse
these uh statute limitations on child
sexual abuse and so it is going to
become the norm
george morris was accused of sexual
misconduct against two minors dating
back to the 1970s
in the wake of his lifetime ban he
sought arbitration and lost he's also
fighting a civil case in the courts
against his accuser
george morris's lawyer has told us that
he denies any improper conduct
you'll see is the higher that people
kind of rise up in their sport or the
better they get or the more well-known
they get i think there's just more at
stake and when there's more at stake
people's behavior starts to change
and so for us you know really take into
account the competitiveness of the sport
but also reminding people constantly
that it's not all about winning at the
end of the day we've got to make sure
that athletes are safe and that may mean
that we don't win sometimes and that's
okay
our community for sure stands behind
the rights for victims we want the best
for our young
and we want the best for our old so it's
not an attack on safe sport it's not an
attack
on anybody
but it's a dialogue
is this the best application
[Music]
i think that as a reporter
i'm really grateful to those who were
willing
to open up their lives to us
to sit down and talk to us to explain
about what had happened to them not just
the abuse but what led up to it
one of the things that maggie kearing
has done for the sport
is she's allowed other young people to
step out of the shadows to break their
own silence
he took away
my sense of self
who i was you know
my
character was very much built around him
and everything he had taught me
so he shattered who i was the person
like
after that i felt lost i didn't know who
i was anymore and even now i'm still
trying to find myself again who i am as
an individual not
in that
family you know with those people around
me influencing who i am
[Music]
you